[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigos la invasión rusa
de Ucrania no sólo está cambiando
radicalmente la geopolítica la seguridad
y la forma de ver el mundo de Europa
también está suponiendo enormes cambios
para la propia Rusia Y a medida que pasa
el tiempo estos irá notando más y más y
más en un reciente vídeo aquí en
visualpolitik y os contamos como las
sanciones a Rusia están logrando muchos
de los objetivos que se habían fijado
Rusia es en términos cuantitativos el
país más sancionado de todo el mundo
concretamente el 2023 arrancó con 13.600
sanciones y restricciones de todo tipo
sobre el estado ruso las empresas del
país o muchos oligarcas cercanos al
kremlin de todas ellas casi 11.000
fueron impuestas tras la invasión de
Ucrania el día 24 de febrero de 2022
para que os hagáis una idea y podéis
comparar sobre Irán el segundo país más
sancionado del mundo es un poco más de
4.000 sanciones y restricciones y sobre
Siria y Corea del Norte unas 2.600 y
2100 respectivamente
y eso no es todo las economías
occidentales y en general la mayor parte
de los aliados de Ucrania han hecho
esfuerzos titánicos para librarse
progresivamente de todo aquello que
proceda de Rusia su gas su petróleo el
dinero de los oligarcas todo excepto una
cosa los suministros del sector nuclear
ruso
hablamos concretamente de rosatoma un
enorme Grupo Industrial propiedad del
gobierno ruso que por ahora ha escapado
de las sanciones ha quedado libre por un
motivo hoy por hoy lo que ofrece esta
empresa es mucho más difícil de
reemplazar que los mismísimos
hidrocarburos Así que a pesar de los
enormes esfuerzos que ha hecho zelensky
mañana tarde y noche para presionar a
sus aliados para que también sancionen a
rosatom hasta ahora no lo ha conseguido
9 de enero de 2023 Ucrania Espera que la
Unión Europea incluya la rusa tome en
las próximas sanciones y ojo que
hablamos Ni más ni menos que de la
empresa Estatal rusa de energía atómica
Y eso eso no es todo este gigante del
sector nuclear es virtualmente la única
empresa rusa que podemos decir que
realmente está a la altura de las
mejores del mundo en su sector ya sea
por tecnología competitividad costes o
calidad y es algo así como la gran
excepción del tejido Industrial ruso un
entorno productivo que queréis que os
diga se caracteriza por su ineficiencia
su corrupción desmedida y un profundo
desfase tecnológico con respecto a sus
contrapartes occidentales Pero eso con
esta empresa no es así Más bien todo lo
contrario claro a ver que la industria
occidental haya sido vapuleada por las
políticas antinucleares de las últimas
décadas pues lógicamente ha contribuido
a que los gane cuota de Mercado ahora
bien Qué es realmente rosatón A qué se
dedican concretamente Por qué no se han
impuesto sanciones sobre esta empresa es
decir hay motivos para sancionar al
gigante nuclear ruso Qué papel juega
esta compañía en el entramado político
económico y militar de la Rusia de
Vladimir Putin Pues bien en este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas y algunas más arranquemos
[Música]
la hija mimada de Putin
como seguramente la mayor parte de
vosotros ya sabéis la caída de la unión
soviética vino seguida de un período de
varios años de profunda crisis donde se
registró una enorme debacle económica y
también industrial y obviamente el
sector nuclear no fue una excepción a
pesar de que la unión soviética fue una
enorme potencia en energía nuclear civil
por ejemplo fue la URSS donde nació la
primera central nuclear del mundo que
introdujo electricidad a la red lo hizo
en 1954 la central de offsnis con apenas
5 megavatios de potencia hizo historia
Pero eso solo iba a ser el principio de
un largo larguísimo camino desde
entonces los soviéticos diseñaron o
construyeron más de 60 reactores
nucleares distribuidos por todo el país
y por el resto del bloque comunista
formado por un sinfín de países
satélites consiguieron así un importante
knowhat y una buena reputación al menos
hasta el accidente nuclear de chernóbil
en 1986 entonces lógicamente pues Todo
cambió pero bien El caso es que cuando
cayó la URSS También cayó todo el tejido
Industrial del Estado algunas de estas
industrias tradicionales nunca llegaron
a otras lo hicieron pero a un nivel
mucho peor que su competencia occidental
y otras en cambio fueron reforzadas con
mimo por parte del gobierno y sabéis que
este último caso fue precisamente el de
rosatón
el propio Vladimir Putin se tomó como un
asunto personal y prioritario reflotar
la industria nuclear para ello en 2006
promulgó una ley que buscaba crear todo
un marco estratégico a largo plazo para
el sector nuclear y Poco después en 2007
el propio Putin fundó rosatom como una
corporación Estatal detrás de esta
decisión estuvo la preocupación del
gobierno ruso por la creciente brecha
entre la demanda y el suministro de
Electricidad es decir que con rosatón
pretendían solucionar de una vez por
todas la escasez eléctrica y evitar Así
que siguiese perjudicando a la economía
además durante la década de los 90 al no
tener un productor de referencia Rusia
se había quedado fuera del mercado
Internacional de la energía nuclear para
que os hagáis una idea entre principios
de los 90 y mediados de los años 2000 en
el mundo se construyeron más de 100
reactores nucleares en cuya construcción
y diseño Rusia no pudo participar es
decir que Moscú comprendieron que se
estaban perdiendo un gran negocio
Así que como solemos decir por aquí
dicho y hecho rosatom nació con un
brutal impulso financiero por parte del
Estado Ruso y con el propio Vladimir
Putin involucrado al 100% en esta misión
de hecho es el mismo el que decide quién
dirige esta compañía y Quién hace los
nombramientos más relevantes
El caso es que con esta empresa pública
la energía nuclear rusa ha vuelto a
abrirse paso y a día de hoy es ya uno de
los mayores actores internacionales en
el sector de la energía nuclear Pero
para ser más claros Me basta con daros
un solo dato de los 53 reactores
nucleares que estaban en construcción en
todo el mundo A mediados del 2022 20
estaban siendo construidos por rosatov y
de ellos 17 estaban fuera de Rusia es
decir que hablamos de una cuota de
Mercado de casi el 40% y ojo porque no
es precisamente un mundo donde sea fácil
entrar tan solo Francia y Corea del Sur
están también construyendo reactores
fuera de sus respectivas fronteras pero
apenas participan en un par de proyectos
cada uno pero hay ahí no termina todo la
empresa rusa también se encarga de
muchos casos del mantenimiento Y la
supervisión de los reactores nucleares
de tecnología rusa que hay repartidos
por todo el planeta de aproximadamente
el 20% de los casi 450 reactores en
operaciones que podemos encontrar hoy en
todo el mundo en otras palabras que
podemos decir Sin temor a equivocarnos
de vida ha logrado dominar el mercado
nuclear internacional al menos
convertirse en el actor más importante
los rusos son hiper competitivos nadie
en la organización para la cooperación y
el desarrollo económico puede competir
con lo que ofrecen marcan el machega
director del centro de energía y clima
del instituto francés de relaciones
internacionales sorprendidos Pues
esperad un momento porque todavía hay
mucho más que contar solo acabamos de
empezar
al final si lo pensáis un momento el
motivo por el que occidente no ha
sancionado a rosado no puede ser solo
sus exportaciones de reactores nucleares
Al fin y al cabo Estados Unidos no tiene
ni se plantea tener reactores nucleares
rusos y en Europa Pues digamos que la
energía nuclear Lleva años marginada y
ahora que está resurgiendo pues
lógicamente se está optando
mayoritariamente por proveedores de
tecnología nuclear occidentales o
surcoreanos pero no rusos Entonces no se
sanciona de una vez por todas a todos
Qué hay en juego para que esta
posibilidad por ahora haya sido
completamente descartada Pues bien aquí
llega quizás la parte más interesante de
toda esta historia prestad mucha pero
que mucha atención
[Música]
átomos made inrasia
a ver las sanciones financieras las
restricciones a la compra de tecnología
o las sanciones al gas el petróleo ruso
se impusieron de forma relativamente
rápida sin embargo en el momento en el
que preparamos Este vídeo y cuando ya
transcurrido un año de la invasión
rosatoma ha conseguido librarse de
cualquier castigo restricción y esto
obviamente tiene que tener una
explicación y sí la tiene esta empresa
no solo se dedica al diseño y la
construcción de reactores nucleares sino
que también enriquece uranio
a pesar de que aquí sí que podemos
encontrar importantes proveedores
occidentales Rosa Tómese el mayor
productor mundial de uranio enriquecido
con cerca del 30% de la producción y
casi la mitad de toda la capacidad
mundial además controla el 17% del
mercado global de combustibles para
reactores nucleares y según la propia
prensa 73 reactores nucleares en 13
países diferentes funcionan gracias a su
combustible y no hablamos solo de las
viejas centrales de origen soviético en
2021 por ejemplo rosatón proporcionó
casi una cuarta parte de todo el
combustible nuclear usado por las
centrales nucleares de Estados Unidos
además se estima que incluso en un
escenario de cambio de proveedores los
rusos retendrán al menos un 15% del
pastel en Estados Unidos a corto y medio
plazo esto es debido a que resulta un
proceso muy lento y costoso
especializarse en la producción de
combustible nuclear a escala y precio
razonables
y evidentemente su cuota de Mercado en
Europa pues no es menor
los rusos proporcionan en torno al 20%
de todo el uranio que importa la Unión
Europea tan solo por detrás de
nigerikazan así como el 26% de todo el
uranio enriquecido de hecho de vez en
cuando todavía se pueden ver por los
cielos europeos aviones de carga rusos
volando a países como Hungría o
Eslovaquia con combustible nuclear
Gracias precisamente a las excepciones
que se introdujeron a la prohibición de
entrada de aviones rusos si transportan
combustible nuclear pues pueden entrar
Ahora bien Por qué todo esto es tan
importante hablamos realmente de algo
tan imprescindible como para dejar a
rosatón fuera de las sanciones
occidentales pues queridos amigos amigas
Lo cierto es que sí Y puede que no sea
exactamente por lo que estáis pensando
así que veámoslo
[Música]
la influencia estratégica
Rosa Tom es una empresa enorme con un
gran porfolio de contratos en el sector
nuclear para que os hagáis una idea en
2021 reportó unos beneficios de 20.000
millones de dólares Así que no hablamos
precisamente de una compañía pequeña y
no solo eso el holding a tome en el
goprom en el que significa gran parte de
la actividad de rosato tenía ese mismo
año un portfolio de pedidos en el
extranjero de cerca de 140.000 millones
de dólares a ejecutar durante la próxima
década Y sí algunos de los contratos de
construcción de reactores nucleares que
engrosan toda esta enorme cantidad de
proyectos están Precisamente en países
de la otan algunos incluso supuestos
aliados de Ucrania fijaos 27 de agosto
de 2022 Hungría avanza la construcción
de reactores nucleares de fabricación
rusa a pesar de la guerra de Moscú en
Ucrania las obras en la planta de pax
comenzarán en las próximas semanas dijo
el ministro de relaciones exteriores de
Hungría 30 de julio de 2022 la rusa Tom
firma un nuevo contrato de construcción
para una central nuclear turca el
gobierno Turco tiene como objetivo
comenzar a operar el primer reactor de
la planta que tendrá un total de 4.800
megavatios antes de las elecciones
generales el próximo año el presidente
allí perdogan sugirió anteriormente que
Turquía podría trabajar con Rusia en la
construcción de dos plantas más Pues
bien la construcción de reactores y su
mantenimiento posterior es con
diferencia el negocio más lucrativo para
esta compañía
de hecho os vamos a dar otro dato las
importaciones anuales de uranio y
combustible nuclear desde Rusia
realizadas por Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea Son imprescindibles para estos
países pero apenas suponen pagar mil
millones de dólares cada año que sí es
mucho dinero pero no tiene nada que ver
con los cerca de 200.000 millones que se
importaban de Rusia en hidrocarburos
justo antes de la guerra y tampoco tiene
nada que ver con lo que ingresa rosatov
con su negocio de reactores nucleares
Pero entonces con todo esto puede que os
estéis haciendo una pregunta Enrique y
no se podría sancionar a los Atom para
evitar que pueda construir nuevos
reactores y centrales pero seguirles
comprando el uranio y El combustible
nuclear hasta que se pueda sustituir en
su totalidad Pues sí Lo cierto es que sí
Y eso sería Probablemente lo que más
daño les haría Pero hay dos
inconvenientes
por un lado dar este paso en un mercado
tan restringido y con pocos proveedores
como este podría hacer que la propia
Rusia estuviera dispuesta a sacrificar
esos ingresos para dejar a occidente sin
su combustible nuclear y esto en Estados
Unidos y Europa podría causar verdaderos
problemas de abastecimiento para las
centrales en un momento de elevados
precios de los hidrocarburos
y luego hay otro problema y es que no
hay tantos proveedores de tecnología
nuclear para centrales modernas Es decir
para entendernos qué prohibir importar
estas tecnologías pues probablemente
generaría un cuello de botella de
pedidos a la industria nuclear civil de
países como Estados Unidos Francia o
Corea del Sur un cuello de botella que
amenazaría el suministro energético
mundial y lo haría Precisamente en el
que se espera que sea el mayor periodo
de electrificación de la historia de la
humanidad ya sabéis debido al
cumplimiento de objetivos climáticos
algo de lo que por cierto ya os hemos
hablado en varias ocasiones aquí en
visualpolitik
Así que la realidad es que les guste o
no Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
tienen que ser muy cautosas a la hora de
imponer sanciones contra rosetón Y ese
es precisamente el motivo por el que
hasta ahora esta empresa ha salido
indemne ahora bien es esto algo
Irreversible pues no Por supuesto que no
De hecho tanto Estados Unidos como la
Unión Europea tienen ya planes para
impulsar su producción de uranio
enriquecido y combustible para centrales
fijaos Estados Unidos redobla esfuerzos
para poner fin a la dependencia del
combustible nuclear ruso la Casa Blanca
está priorizando el desarrollo de
capacidad Nacional de enriquecimiento de
uranio y predijo que los legisladores
claves se alinearán de modo que el plan
de fabricación de combustible pueda
estar en marcha para 2025 las nucleares
incluidas en el plan re Power you de la
Unión Europea la comisión europea ha
adoptado formalmente el plan re Power
you cuyo objetivo es reducir rápidamente
la dependencia de la Unión Europea de
los combustibles fósiles rusos el plan
destaca la importancia de una acción
coordinada para reducir la dependencia
de los materiales y del ciclo del
combustible nuclear ruso pero claro
hasta que todo se materialice pues Rosa
Tom seguirá teniendo una importancia
clave para su suministro el riesgo que
se corre ahora es que la dependencia de
occidente permita a esta empresa
convertirse en una especie de bypass
para las sanciones y desviar tecnologías
compra de suministros y beneficios para
financiar la campaña militar
[Música]
por lo pronto ya ha participado
activamente en la invasión a Ucrania ya
que es el actual operador de la central
nuclear de zaporíja y también su
propietario de facto mientras está
permanezca ocupada además la empresa
actúa de acuerdo a las órdenes del
gobierno ruso a la hora de operar esta
central ucraniana que es la más grande
de Europa con un total de siete
reactores desde el principio de la
ocupación de la central se han estado
conectando y desconectando unidades a
capricho del kremlin para minar la moral
de los ucranianos y evitar que obtengan
dinero exportando electricidad a sus
vecinos europeos
y de hecho este es uno de los grandes
argumentos que el gobierno ucraniano
esgrime para pedir que se sancione lo
antes posible a esta empresa Pero como
habéis visto incluso a pesar de su
colaboración con la guerra las cosas no
resultan en este caso nada fáciles En
definitiva que resaltó más que como un
enorme balón financiero para el kremlin
que también lo es funciona Sobre todo
como una baza de presión estratégica a
nivel político como una especie de línea
roja en la que desgraciadamente en este
caso Rusia sí tiene ventaja pero ahora
ha llegado hasta aquí turno para ti
crees que Estados Unidos y Europa harían
bien poniendo en riesgo su producción de
energía nuclear para sancionar a rosetón
puede ser esta empresa la última gran
baza estratégica de Putin fuera del
terreno de batalla Pues bien déjanos tus
opiniones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y hablamos debate Y por
supuesto si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a visualpolitik si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]